it was such a big deal to me when you um
when you
came on my program you did a residency
there for a week and it it just uh meant
the world to all of us and was very
important and one of the things that was
so cool is that you weren't someone who
did a lot of things like that so it had
a lot of meaning you weren't someone
that was always out there on television
so it really had a great weight for me
and for you Jim and for everybody at the
show and it was a it was a big deal
and then I find out
that you had done some television back
in the 60s and some of it maybe against
your will because you're with Buffalo
Springfield was pretty wild you're in an
episode of manix that's right
it is
one of the craziest things manic's a
detective show with Mike Connors and he
comes into a he comes into a bar to
check out the scene
and in the background is Buffalo
Springfield you guys are playing but the
camera doesn't even focus on you guys
and this pardon I'm sorry if I'm going
to anger any Mannix fans out there but
this kind of run-of-the-mill
60s
show is going on that no one watches
anymore and the real story is in the
background do you remember that at all
do you remember being there yeah there
were a couple of those we did
I remember that one whose idea was let's
get Buffalo Springfield oh I don't know
yeah I don't know but I know there are
managers thought this was a great
opportunity right to move into
television
did you ever notice and you know we're
kind of far back all the action's
happening up front we are 50 feet away
from the cameras you know I don't think
we even looked at it that's the thing is
we just kept going right it's like
because we don't watch you know I didn't
watch Mannix right I wasn't on a manic's
uh fan okay well we're breaking but I do
know what Mannix looked like yes I can
picture the show I've seen it yeah you
know he had uh yeah he was oh he's he
was always jumping out of his car just
before it crashed I think that was his
move he was I think in a Mustang and it
was always uh he would always he was
about to go off the cliff because they
had you know fixed his brakes or
something I think um I don't know how he
got uh reinsured after the 35th crash
but I was watching and there's and it's
funny because the 60s in particular is a
Time
I'm fascinated by it because there's
such a culture Clash
TV's been pretty much more or less the
same for a long time just an extension
of radio same old guys writing it
cranking it out and then suddenly the
world changes 63 64 65 everything's
changing and I love watching
there was a show that you did was it the
what's the Hollywood palette the
Hollywood Palace oh yeah the Hollywood
Palace and uh
and you guys are great right I mean you
guys are it's I can't remember what they
played on the Hollywood Palace was it we
did Mr Soul Mr Soul yeah that's right
you could start with for what it's worth
yeah what it's worth in Mr soul and then
you switched in and it's a it's called
the tape switched in they taped this
whole thing you know yeah it was the
record and so you were playing along to
the record but was there any live aspect
to it uh there might have been some live
singing yeah uh I feel like your vocals
and your solo were live
um well they were live I watched it and
your solo feels live oh yeah oh good and
the bass player was uh looking the other
way yeah yeah that's because he wasn't
there so he had to use our road manager
looking looking the other way so there's
a guy who's the MC and this is the part
I love and he comes out and he's it's
very what kind of borscht belt old
school show business I I'm not sure who
it is but he comes out and he goes next
we got Buffalo Springfield These Guys
these guys have made had so many hits in
the last year I made so much money they
could buy Buffalo and Springfield and
you're like what
you guys have to just all right uh and
you can just think there's like some 55
year old writers in the back give us a
joke for Buffalo Springfield what's what
the [ __ ] is that that's right they had
to have it
but you know we didn't again Conan we
didn't even notice yeah yeah we didn't
yeah that stuff never even had never
even got on our screen right because
we're just we did a TV show
it's like we went to Mars
exactly and then we left Mars that's
what it looks like and I and I think
it's it's uh it it looks like okay we've
entered this world that you kind of have
to show up at
you know and just as yourself we're
gonna yeah we're gonna show up and we're
gonna do this uh
uh and but we're entering a world that's
uh I mean
I remember watching you guys on the
Buffalo Springfield on the Smothers
Brothers and again it was great it was
an amazing performance you guys gave but
they kept doing cutaways to Tommy
Smothers doing bits while you're doing
for what it's worth yeah and I thought
ah
huh I don't know about that that's
television yeah that's a pretty heavy
song yeah
people to think about that
but he says like when Stephen sings like
there's a man with a gun over there they
cut to Tommy Smothers holding a gun and
the audience laughs and I'm thinking
yeah I don't know I don't know if this
is it wasn't genius Conan it wasn't
genius really
I thought all television comedy was
genius
[Music]